hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to fatal frame - now I
got plenty of sleep and I'm no longer
tired so I don't need to worry about
falling asleep in the middle of this are
saying something that I'm going to
regret so instead of doing that I'll
intentionally to say things that I'm
going to regret as we play this game
also I'm trying to remember exactly what
happened before I know that we got
eyeball oh yeah that's right we need to
go to the doll room that's right okay
I'm back in it that was the shortest
time for me to remember exactly where I
was before I got lost again didn't do
that before did the camera change that
way before I know okay that's this
curtain swaying in the wind there
nothing for me to worry about just yet
so we need to go back to the doll room
because we got the eyes that we needed
which were the last component because it
was like huh I put the arms in the head
back on but I don't know exact that
music pick up that much before I was so
deliriously tired that I know it barely
registered that things were getting
really really really creepy I inserted
the glass eyes into the doll actually
need to turn down my volume because it's
getting kind of ridiculous you heard a
sound coming from the box behind the
doll okay so I need to put those dolls
in 9 and 3 the only question is are they
at 6 o'clock or they at midnight where
they're facing now the device seems to
be working now good great oh they need
to face each other that's right okay oh
god the hands are moving all the hands
are moving oh why the hands moving
alright button
okay Oh dad yes almost there we are when
the dolls face each other you heard a
sound coming from the large box cool ah
wasn't that done okay hey you can't just
suddenly ambush me like that I knew that
you were gonna be ghosts I didn't have a
chance to run away oh no I need some
herbal medicine like how am i crushing
this up and taking this herbal medicine
just in the split section where I need
to go anyway I need to upgrade my camera
anyway we just go ahead and wait no let
me put a spirit orb in sensitivity
because I think I remember someone
saying that was the actual damaging
function of it that should be enough and
now I just get back a little bit come at
me I don't mean to kill stop acting like
I'm trying to do this BAM
where's your where's your partner
where's your friend put your friend okay
I need to make it happen if not being in
the camera all the time I actually need
to use outside the camera I just thought
it was good oh hey there you are I just
thought it might have been a little bit
better I was just ready to go whenever I
could that wasn't that hey hey hey oh
hey okay so they are very not happy when
I take a picture of the wrong one why do
I kill who it is one of them not the
right one
well that wasn't where I was facing whoa
hey
ah that wasn't it oh [ __ ] who's coming
after ah oh god there's like no time I
can't back out of it then I can't back
out of in that regard I can't I can't I
can't take the time so I just got to
stay in my thing I got to get them both
in front of me at the same time before I
actually do that if that's the ticket
why do I want now there's one I think I
saw yeah there's yeah okay let me get
this one and I'll quickly flip the other
come on quick quick quick flip flip flip
ah gotcha ha ha okay now spawn behind me
please so that I can have some room to
work here now crap that's not behind me
at all
Oh God there I've got there all around
me and they're like a swarm so I get
this one to be able to
mm okay flip flip left left left left
left left left left left
Hey oh no I got the right one okay cool
cool cool I still don't know how I'm
supposed to be able to make the
determination that one's different than
the other I know - my Bloods in my
nature I'm a warrior
oh whoa hey hey sucksby yeah I got the
right one I think whatever had the
spirit in it I think at this point that
doll had the spirit in it the glowing
crystal is lying where the girl doll was
standing I had best pick it up Hale
purple Cruz is anybody gonna be
whispering in my ear after this oh hey
how's it going welcome to the party
am I gonna go underground now am I gonna
see the ball and with my own eyes okay
cool I have to climb a ladder down a
first I have to listen to some horrible
moaning from across the beyond table
Bert people I don't know I try not to it
just happens oh I try making me angry
I just um any question I just makes me
angry telling me why do I kill it gives
me murderous feelings like that most of
the horror games that I assume I assume
that my character is actually not all
well together and probably is the cause
of all this horrible horrible miss oh
well this looks lovely I'm glad that
this is the thing oh I didn't even know
that okay well I got more months from
the beyond to listen to see what they
have for me I'm the Guru God it's
pronounced envelope
it's pronounced doom and it's pronounced
koumei you got that one right
you can never leave maybe because you're
trapped underground in some horrible
horrible town there's got to be like a
terrible reason why they're actually
doing this why they're actually causing
twins to have to throw the other one
into a pit of floor there's got to be
right it can't be a good thing
and who who's maintaining these candles
here these can't be still burning I
thought this flashlight wasn't working
very well I know where you're dying back
oh it's giggles McGee how's it going
chuckles mcnutty apron yeah what are you
gonna do oh my god ticket yep
hey how about a run oh no no no what are
you even doing I wasn't with the Bologna
it's a bunch of bull that's a bunch of
bull that's a I didn't do that that was
the character that was a cutscene I had
no control over that I would never have
done that
you dropped the camera obscura in the
flashlight when you were on the ground
then how did you see the ladder you
can't use the viewfinder until you get
the camera obscura back well I'll just
go back down then chapter seven saw a
the mechanism is sticking you probably
won't be able to open it from this side
great good oh the legs of a doll
sticking out from underneath oh good
this is where things go horribly wrong
because they take away my weapon this
actually might be like one of the
scarier episodes is because they
actually take away my means to fight
which would be great like no seriously
it would be totally great if that was
what they are actually going for you I
don't know if it is but we're gonna find
out soon enough anyway what is this on
the ground is in another camera oh boy a
second camera obscura no it's more herbs
hmmm this is what I need more 420 blaze
it for my terrible terrible terrible
thing I think all of these tarps are
just covering more dolls which is great
okay what do you got for me oh I sure
wish I could take a picture of that whoa
hello
oh hey hey hey
hey get away from me ah you're probably
one hit ko no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no oh
well that one's locked too I probably
shouldn't the gone this way I probably
will eat oh hi
are you sorry are you the slightly less
keeping it together one are you the dead
one that was cast into the beyond good
question well I mean it's a blue glow
it's not necessarily a red glow I don't
know if that means that still that it's
probably deadly I'm just gonna go off
the base or something that is deadly
okay what's in here Oh more herbs
good I need to blaze it every bit more
and more that makes sense this is the
first video recorded today obviously
everything I say is not gonna make much
sense than anything I ever say makes
much sense in this entire series but hey
is what it is I guess
all right moving on so where did we run
off to is the question like where did we
just go I know that we're probably in
the other house at this point the one
that I couldn't get it get into from the
overhead bridge so this means that
there's got to be something here that I
need or at least I might be able to find
my you around here well I got up I got a
glowy ghost the glowy ghosts in here but
I can't do anything about it I might be
able to get back in the underground
passage from the other way if I can find
a way out of this house and then go back
around on the outside and then
underground again don't seem like a big
waste of time though like what would
even be the point of that if that was
all I needed to do to get my camera back
but hey it's this game's choice it's not
me okay so that doors locked that door
was locked this was a big inner - Tommy
room just straight down this hallway
should leave something or other
no more Omo oh boy more glowy ghosts
okay cool
damn it all these all these doors are
held shut by powerful forces so what
does that mean for me what do I need to
do for another way I mean no don't think
I don't think it was a door to get
outside just yet
what's there all through here okay maybe
this does lead outside doesn't makes
more sense this manner would make more
sense hello
oh hey how's it going crimson diary
because of Y Itsuki has been taken away
for somewhere how come Itsuki did
nothing to her it's all her fault for
running away good place the blame on
everybody else don't take any
responsibility for your own life that's
how this town all went to [ __ ] alright
stop spinning in circles that's like the
most annoying thing about this then try
lifting it you find this really heavy
who could swing this uh Pyramid Head man
something like that okay it don't look
like anything inside how about this
where does this go yeah stick your head
face-first into the doors that you're
trying to open secretively
okay wait where did that go that oh it
just looped around okay so both of those
doors led to the okay all right god I
got it
okay I guess there's nothing else for me
then I just got to get out of here
okay wandering off into the unknown
hopefully this door actually works yeah
it does that's a weird camera angle but
her a ghost and he goes to use now it'd
be the time to attack me
I have no defenses at all whatsoever
don't lean in the open film reel 5
nothing there nothing even to look at
there must have been something painted
on it at one time but it's all worn away
that makes me question how old is this
place that things are worn away and yet
the candles are all still lit like long
enough for parchment to be worn that's
an incredibly long time or ink to fade
off the parchment old sandals are put
there so it must be towards the front of
the house so I should be able to get out
over
you something's reflecting more herbs or
oh those herbs they were bad herbs Oh No
okay ah this is bad
how you seem to be in already why do I
need to open up don't go they don't get
me bro ah okay where do I go what am i
doing why I thought it I thought I could
go here what's going on okay
alright then why everybody else I need
to go find the camera obscura because
apparently I seem to be in a bit of
trouble here so where am I supposed to
go now oh it ain't good am I supposed to
be able to run back until I go somewhere
what do we need to run away from
everybody hey I'm so defenseless then
again this just print in perspective
I'm just kind of a little girl you know
stalking alone no one to help wandering
haunted village with ghosts and Ghoulies
okay what's a people did I go through
here I don't know if I went through I
might have gone through her oh yeah I
did no did I yeah I definitely did
so there's back the way I came so I
can't go through the front door and I
can't go back the way I came therefore
what the hell am I supposed to do
I don't think Sai is gonna be there
anymore Oh nope cutscene this is right
way what do i do also lost my you my you
I knew to be you my you my you stop
sandy like a creeper come to your sister
oh wait don't come to your sister I
change my mind don't do that don't come
at all you're not my sister
I knew it how did I knew it I'm just
that smart
probably not but here I go I'm running
away leaving you alone I did not do that
I didn't even hit the end of it what am
I trying to hide hide from a ghost that
can walk right through walls how
intelligent of me okay where am I going
there uh seems to be broken it seems to
be intact to me
you're drunk I am trying to hide aren't
I I'm just trying to run away like it
stopped spinning in circles damn it I
don't see anything here yeah oh oh you
see a door beyond the broken bookcase it
doesn't seem like it was used much okay
I don't think I read that right at all
by the way I think I read that totally
and completely wrong here stop spinning
in circles dammit god dammit
could you just go the way I want you to
oops
no I don't think so no I'm okay
no sound by you uh-oh where was it no I
don't over the knew I just saw what you
were I gonna open the door for you I
thought I was gonna get the chance to
say before this but now I am oh no way
no way no hell no ain't gonna happen
goodbye you ain't gonna trick me I
wouldn't even want to hang out with my
you anyway okay smokey on the Shelf the
crest with Apollonian tree is design is
carved on the brass key I'm having
trouble reading today there's a doll
with a red cord tied to it on the shelf
kimono looks exactly like the one the
spirit you just saw was wearing you mean
by you right why did you leave
what that was in Mayas voice I didn't
leave nobody back then I don't know what
you're talking about
oh-oh-oh
whoa speed demon uh-oh Hey
okay I got the palo in key okay that was
probably gonna kill me in one hit I was
gonna have to game over and do it all
over again from the same point which
would be really douchey cuz it didn't
let me save no no oh oh yes hiding
hiding great great choice great great
choice
great choice the people of these horror
games just leave the town or at least
try she didn't even try
totally oh come on don't try it like
stay for like another minute you can
hold your position
cheese why not be absolutely certain
instead of wiggling around like a wiggle
worm yeah somehow that fooled the ghost
somehow that fooled the ghost yeah sure
I believe that
okay okay there's a single doll standing
on the mechanical device on the shelf
maybe there are two buttons on the
device maybe it works just like the
other device you saw okay so I need to
go back and I need to get the other doll
which was in the closet there I believe
so just back one more room and I'll be
able to grab the doll so once I do that
I'm willing to bet that the ghost is
probably still out there and I just need
to avoid it but I need to go back grab
that doll put it on the thing and make
him face each other cuz it's creepy like
that
notes not going say you're not my you
finally got what you deserved
can grab that thank you
okay no thank you
yeah no no nose here don't you okay
those men those men goddamn why did you
spin rifle in there it's the worst
timing you could possibly have you
dingus parity dingle donger oh no I got
to hide again
yeah I'll hide in the closet do I get a
hide again I have no idea
yeah damn hadn't I'm a stealthy hider
I'm just hiding
no no lever find me no one will ever
okay I think maybe not you never know
what these things I'll just use my
loudest thunderous footsteps to get
where I need to go Oh boom boom boom
boom no entail word a wham bam bam creak
okay I'm having issues honey
alright left button yep that did the
trick right button okay I didn't do damn
thing
whee-hoo haha Oh was there BAM you're
too small sound come from the door on
the left is just like it unlocked good
right good for me now the dolls can be
all they face me again okay
Oh more cutscene great
no I think I'm gonna go going exactly
what I wanted to do in the first place
oh wait am I just gonna go back well
that was the point of coming over there
in the first place if I knew that it was
this filled of ghosts then I wouldn't
have been so happy to eagerly throw
myself headfirst into it so barely that
house is just flubber duct and I'm just
gonna carry on with my new film reel I'm
gonna go see it in the projector and
then live on my life without my sister
finally I will there can only be one
which is me so no one else so my you can
suck it I'm pretty bitter aren't I fight
a twin I wouldn't be so happy but I only
have a brother and he's awesome his name
is Tom and he's cool cooler than your
brother my brother could be too braixen
probably not actually no I don't know he
has like that he has the the rage
strength when he gets angry he is very
strong cuz you got the German Korean
Korean warrior blood combined with
German back wait what is this there's a
girl with a flashlight in there was that
supposed to be me
who's filming a girl with a flashlight
that's the first house that I went into
that's the first house I ever been
those Osaka house or something oh then
oh okay that's lovely
showing the murder of that poor lady
great okay thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you this whole town is
just filled with such love and
acceptance that I can't hardly stand it
I think I'm gonna vomit bye
no thanks I'm gonna go get my camera
obscure that I dropped like a doof
cuz I'm an idiot whatever then climb
down the ladder yes please I don't have
a flashlight either it's gonna be pitch
black oh no it there it is I can see it
from all the candles that were laid here
eons ago and fueled by dinosaur poop
great oh well that's not good hey blind
oh hey blind oh you want to come over
here hey blonde oh my man
Flemming doesn't seem to be damaged in
the flashlights unfortunately do okay
good now I can go into the other house
again and finally vanquish all the
demons and then I will be able to carry
on screw you saw a screw you in your
face okay I'll go back up I thought that
I thought I could have sworn that wasn't
the Oh supposed to be accessible from
that place I don't remember
good finally it's been a while since I
was able to save I was afraid I was
going to game over and you guys we're
gonna have to watch me trudge all the
way back once more because blur good
luck that's what I described it to
Asians that I don't like blabber and
also impenetrable pits of hell are also
described as our
alright who's up first to be obliterated
back into the demon times with camera
obscura who's after it who wants some
you want some BAM you got some was that
not do it for you is that not good
enough I wasn't in focus I apologize
oh no no I'm sorry oh there we go thank
you
hello faces
oh no you've been obliterated you must
go back to hell yes thank you the
presents you were feeling in front of
the doors gone now good I didn't want to
feel any presents anyway hmm
I hate Christmas me oh wait was it what
the what is this this is supposed to be
okay so a bunch of pole stamping priests
wait didn't I see this before I thought
I saw this one this is one everything
was going oh okay that's one of the
mourners the guys who have the eyes
gouged out so they can't see into the
ball or is that the kusabi was at the
kusabi taking this so each of these
house comes with a projector for some
strange reason what's behind the curtain
did Nathan going this way no I didn't
because this is the other way okay so
this would probably lead to some sort of
front of the house oh that a hole cold
air and the low sound of wind seeps from
the well oh you know that underground
wind which whips through these places
can I see anything nothing an easter egg
no I find then keep your secrets I don't
need them all right
more boxes yay film reel 6 another home
movie to watch for the whole family
ok I guess I might as well watch this
since the projector is right here and
whatever Yanni do I think this is the
last one if unless there are more than 7
ok let me get a better angle on it well
that's the box I know about that because
that was one of the first scares that I
experienced it was the Box ghosts came
out of the Osaka house Oh Saku otaku I
don't know
oh no I'm a ghost
is that it was that it that wasn't
descriptive at all I already knew about
that why did I need ammo Oh memories of
early times when I played this game oh
how I cherish thee ah you're only a few
episodes ago I choose hours and hours
ago at this point because this game is
actually quite long
alright where are you leading me I
imagine it's gonna be some sort of a
duplicate to the other area okay
something reflecting the light type 14
film good cuz I needed more I guess uh
over here okay
yeah this seems to be kind of an
opposite mirror to what I saw in the
other area
got here ooh camera Qin zero power up
lens okay raises damage blasts back okay
inflicts heavier damage than normal and
enables blast back even when it's not a
shudder chance press triangle when
you've charged three or more spirit
points okay alright so it's just a
heavier hit but not like a timed heavy
hit you can use it anytime apparently I
received a letter from mr. McCabe a the
said I should leave the village and
return home before him yawns I brought
the letter here they told me that
Outsiders cannot stay because the
festival is coming soon mr. pattabhi has
special permission to see it
I whispered dia that I would come for
them on the day of the ceremony yay
tense for a moment that acted like she
didn't hear and left it seems they may
all really be planning to leave before
the ceremony occurs that means Itsuki
must still be somewhere in the village -
okay who is it Itsuki again they've been
mentioning Itsuki alot but I don't
exactly remember who that was I mean was
that was that the male twin I think I
remember they're talking about like
there was a male set of twins and I
don't know what they did okay all the
boxes you're sealed sacred water I
haven't been using the sacred water
nearly as much as I have been using the
herbs which is weird because you think I
had a lot of dry mouth from all that
herbal supplements okay ma'am
seems to be luck okay everything locked
there so what else was there anything
else in here I don't think there was
pretty sure I cleared it out okay all
right so now I need to go back and I
need to go back downstairs because I
need to go around or unless is the thing
no I need to go around and check out the
other doors that were also sealed up by
ghosts and hopefully thanks with sha hey
on the way and deal with some other
ghosts at the same time with my newly
found skills of my camera obscura maybe
all that wind that's whipping up from
underneath the ground is just actually
like all demon energy that's coming out
of the devil
somewhere down deep underground because
I could have sworn they said that the
the the blow was supposed to be
underground accessible by that passage
didn't they say that they said that why
do I spin as a circle every single time
I come out of doors it's not fun it's
not fair and I don't like it Oh what do
we got here another ghost oh no not
another
there it is I got it in focus I think oh
no it was not that small before I okay
bye
now what awaits me through this store
alright the presence is now gone I can't
feel it any longer
hello anybody that's okay Oh what was
that that was loud that was like way
louder than anything else I've been in
this game just yet okay oh hi I'll tell
it you stone mirror I can't carry
anymore good it's a mummy sits on a
chest of drawers why that ain't no
normal just doll that's a mummy
where the thing glowing it Sookie told
me to hold the key for his room he said
I can't let anyone go in there
he said if his friend comes give the key
to his friend I'm so happy that it gave
me such an important job it's Sookie's
friend came to the house I got scared
so I hid someone for the important job I
couldn't give him the key cuz I was a
coward yeah who lit all the candles who
lit all the wind though the Amber's many
offerings have been placed on the altar
like shelf
maybe this room was used for some kind
of ritual maybe maybe this whole town
was used for some kind of rule book what
am I looking at well damn it come on
focus here get it together cameraman
spam what do we got what are you looking
at oh hi how's it going male twin there
were male twins I knew it I knew I don't
know if that's Itsuki but I knew there
were male twins I knew that they were
talking about that I knew it I knew it I
remembered things
hey go me I can remember those basic of
instructions that the game gives me okay
bye mommy I'm sure that you won't come
back to haunt me later all right
what have we got here what other Horrors
await us Chloe what's Chloe what's all
glowy there was go there's glowy where
do you go BAM and goodbye thank you for
stopping by
now one were you guarding in this stupid
door that I need to explore yes I know
the presence is now gone I get it that's
how I vanquish the demons with my
exorcism Oh camera ok what is this looks
like another projector room maybe who
there's a clock a grandfather clock let
me just stuff that in my pants that's a
reference from slenderman's mansion from
sundar hat slender mansion was that the
name of it Slenderman chancellor either
way I stuffed a grandfather clock in my
pants in that one and then I walked out
the front door because I was an heirloom
that I needed collect from Slenderman
for some reason don't ask me why I stole
his grandpappy it's old granny okay
there's a mirror of the place where the
lady fell down and went boom and then
came to crawl for my ankles you know
what I meant
that sounded confusing but it was
confusing for me too it's a very strange
experience
I'm sorry Mayu god damn it my you it's
about damn time what the hell
Mayu is in this room I can see that you
tried calling her but she doesn't answer
the quietest call ever bye
I am I'm coming to rescue you look at me
look at me oh well she didn't hear
Oh No Mayu oh no okay locking grave with
a Bell design on the door how many times
do I need a rescue muck no BAM crimson
kimono you know you're not as good as
female twins for some reason so don't
even trip wait why was why was he
dressed in a kimono there aren't kimono
one kimono trim it traditionally the
female garb were children dressed in
kimonos or were they trying to for they
were trying to force the male twins into
the role that is usually accompanied by
female twins because all the dolls in
the other room were all female they were
female dolls and so that is interested
well okay so I needed to find a bail
lock where am I gonna wire our bells
everywhere the day after the ceremony
the day after the ceremony my brother
and Sookie came back alone his hair blue
his black hair was white whereas my
other brother matsuki gone since when -
he disappeared at Sookie doesn't want to
talk he's still nice to me but his eyes
are always sad what happened on the day
of the ceremony
Itsuki gave me a bell my eyes are not
too good the Bell will tell him if I go
near a dangerous place Itsuki said he
was always come when he hears the bell
he said even if I'm hiding away and
crying you will find him huh huh oh
maybe the girl was the little sister
okay nevermind then I'm totally wrong
never mind never mind never mind him
okay I heard something on the floor I
did like a pal I think I heard a bell
did I hear a bell I'm pretty sure I
heard a bell wait was it on the floor
did that say like underneath the floor
more herbs great exactly what I needed
to get higher and higher
okay alrighty then those weird just
gonna act like that didn't happen too
many herbs too much smoke egde so where
am I going now Bell hells bells is that
the bells of hell am I going yeah before
I go down there I need to make sure that
I explore everything up here yeah I get
it yeah bells in here
Bell in here hello bells bells anybody
with bells anybody wanted to I'll just
spin in a circle first because that's
what I always do to cleanse the spirits
into every room that I go and they just
spin in a circle and they don't like
smell the frickin demons 90 film good
good I needed that for some reason
hopefully there's gonna be a 90 powerful
demon that I'm gonna need to vanquish
with that but not just yet oh there's
another series of rooms all right this
is these series of worms that I went
through isn't it okay so if I'm
following through yeah I've already been
in here so I need to go back and then
down the stairs because down the stairs
wait mm-hm
where does that go then okay goes down
here and then that's over there but does
that help me is that where I need to goo
did I go through there yeah I did
because that's where I got out of here
okay so let's go back listen to try not
to go this way let's actually go down
the stairs because I'm pretty sure the
bells said it was coming beneath the
floor so I need to go back that way
right here if I get on yet bells I hear
bells bells I'm not going crazy those
are definitely bells I'm gonna follow
the bells because I'm some sort of cat
lady hello
bells anybody bells bells please bells
bells means friendly right now spinning
in a circle because for some goddamn
reason that's all I can goddamn do I
just expect every fan art that's drawn
of me if playing this game is just me
dressed up as my me oh here in a skirt
just spinning endlessly in circles over
and over and over again because I can't
help it so the demons that I ran away
from first we're over here I might be
able to expel them
which battle thankful for getting out of
here I suspect been in a circle
I want a circle good yes thank you thank
you very much or how about over here
what about over here over here we Circle
up not there you go good good good okay
so there doesn't seem to open hey what
are you doing he wants to get your
picture taken you do come on come on
Brett what's it go Brett oh you want to
go Brett want to go want to go Brett
what a girl Brett is there someone over
there oh there is someone over there hey
you want to go don't be sneaking up me
through the walls there come on let's go
let's go bro oh oh come on damn it damn
it's hard to see who's who
okay today get something something at
all something anything area that's some
I guess compared forgive me give me give
me give me give me
if give give give someone come up to the
chopping block you you cube do something
what are you on the backup you scared of
me huh you're afraid you Freight like a
little baby huh
are they just gonna keep running away
for me I'll just take some pictures hit
some pop shots way back for me ha ha ha
I mean if you're not gonna attack me all
I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna go for
you and I got all day and all day
give me there we go that was good [ __ ]
Oh triple shad I'm so good at games oh
so good okay let's come on give me
something you weird white glowing
weirdos Oh No
oops I got a picture of the ceiling nose
very nice I need to keep running away
from me the big goobers come towards me
I'll just keep taking pictures whatever
if I can get all three of them that just
makes my job pretty easy bam bam a
little bit at a time
oh you circling around me
oh this is gonna take a while these
windows yeah yeah I know how about a
blast
oh no that hurt you and the finishing
touches BAM oh good job okay so that's
two down one down and they're trying to
attack me but from so far away are you
still a thing you're still a thing
come on come on hit me yeah yeah hit me
hit me yeah I got your blessing
oh so much standing for your bow oh I
thought I had another combo but I think
you aah he went too far behind the wall
what a goober what a guy must had a
triple combo would have been my first
triple combo but forget like a triple
shot super combo
Oh No here we go oh you ruined my
opportunity I guess you just died up
slightly less spectacular way
okay burn I'm dead bird hurts big death
hurts bear I'm a ghost bird so not gonna
happen this the door is shot fast in
there thick boards nailed over it all
they were nailed in so this was like a
fruitless venture anyway so I didn't
need to kill those a-holes well whatever
I did it anyway and it felt good
what about over here what we got over
here something in the drawer I don't
need more stone mirrors what the stone
mirrors do is they resurrect you if you
just so happen to die which would be
great and all but I've haven't died
because I'm very good at this game now
hey I know you're saying that that
statement but I am I've gotten way
better at this game I've gotten a lot
better
I almost got a triple combo and
everyone's my life are your triple
combos in my sleep when I was a baby
when I when I was in the hospital sick
with pneumonia I got triple combos it's
like yeah thanks I know but I almost got
one so whatever I haven't got one yet
but I almost did and that's what counts
it's better than getting one now I mean
you know I mean you know what I feel if
you know what I feel let me know you
know what I feel now in the comments
below like comment and subscribe if you
know what I mean you know what I'm
saying you know you know you feel me you
feel me in here ow ow ow that hurt okay
where am I going now
all right so I'm downstairs now I do I
need to go back in the regular tatami
room
do I need to go back this way there's
another hallway down here that I could
go through and also on the second floor
I don't think there's anything else on
the second floor I think I just need to
go back through this hallway go to the
big tatami room no I can't be right
where am I going
I don't even know what my objective is
right now like I'm trying to get to my a
which means I'm trying to find a key
which I would assume means I'm trying to
get out of this house there's this kind
of unexplored hallway over here so I
guess I could go over there so let me
just go through the twins room again and
then I will make my way to that area cuz
if that doesn't help me then I'm just
screwed so whatever it is hello also why
do the twins need so many damn rooms
like who cares
oh yeah the twins Yatta Yatta Yatta
everyone knows the twins are great or
whatever just as stupid ceremony just
needs to be let go hello hello hello let
me just do my dance of indecisiveness
for a little bit how about over here
what was over here I'm over here huh
what's over there
okay nothing all right cool that was
good that was good use of my time what
about over here where we're going right
here no okay just gonna spin around more
herbs I thought I picked that up before
whatever just spin in a circle that's
great
hate life right now this really sucks
whatever it's Holi okay okay where does
this lead I've been through here I'm
gonna bend the rear or have I not been
through where's this yeah I been through
here there's another same point over
there okay so this was not a very
beneficial venture for me but there is
another room through there I didn't see
that one before someone try to go
through there
one seconds let me save cuz this is a
pom-pom I know very dramatic for poopy
poopy pom-pom you know you've run out of
things to say on a let's play when
you're just singing along to the bee boo
bah bum bums okay so if I go back
through there that would be a quicker
shot to go where I need to go so I need
just need to go back okay got it I got
it I got it
then through the long hallway then wrap
around and I'll be able to go where I
need to go whoo I am still making good
progress I'll just walk against that
wall for a little bit because screw life
and everything that means going in the
right direction that I wanted to go
hooray
you see this is what I mean when I say
certain controls frustrate me like I'm
totally okay with most of the controls
in this game they're fine especially
when it comes with the battle mechanics
like yes it's supposed to be a little
awkward because you're walking around
with camera attached to your face but
when things do things that I don't want
it to do and I know that I can avoid it
in some way or another like that's what
arcs me that's why I am bred it was also
particularly rage-inducing it's just
because like those things are things
that should be obvious and should be
ready to be done and yet they don't do
okay so that door is locked period so
that means there's not any other way to
go around here except maybe oh no that
just lead it down so I've looked through
everything in here and there's nothing
else to be said except maybe what are
those lead and let me see what you see
what
that might be something there because
there were two doors there was like a
double door that tatami room but I don't
think so
I'm I was searching for the Bell and the
Bell was on the second floor that's
right I think I got distracted a little
bit I forgot that I was supposed to be
hunting for the Bell so the bell sound
came on the second floor so let me try
to go back to the second floor now we
rose the quickest way to the same floor
well oddly enough it was probably in the
room I was just in but I don't think
that actually led all the way to where I
needed to go did it
I don't know where I'm supposed to go I
really don't okay I'm just gonna keep
wandering because I'll get there
eventually I know I'll get there
eventually and that's all the matters
for most people anyway
I'll get iron cotton we're tired about
cutting I play these games long enough I
can't cut I can't stop I won't be
stopped unless I'm [ __ ] going in the
wrong what is this in here did I see
this before oh no it's that stone mirror
again I don't know why that hurts me so
much because I'm going through thro many
doors and I'm actually seeing it in
front of me a lot like I'm just walking
through this house is this a series of
doors why can't the doors just a frickin
open when I goddamn open them and then I
won't have to deal with them again in
the future but no I just have to go
through doors over and over and over and
over again I have to wander the freaking
house over and over and over again so
straight ahead ah yes I'm getting a
little frustrated because I just want to
go where I need to go and I was on the
track with the bells before and now
things have changed and I'm spinning
poofy I've got like so much spit in my
mouth you guys don't want to know about
that but it's a problem that I have to
face in my daily life spit okay where's
that goddamn Bell Oh why it was right
here I looked at the wrong side I looked
the door on the other side to tell me I
was in here was our cat near screws cat
sounds really cool out of the way the
face clipped through hello what are you
gonna do to me
I can't say that was incredibly scary
though
hello oh whoa whoa whoa wait don't don't
walk into it with your stupid spiral
motion [ __ ] where where where where
where where okay little girl your
brother's I I'm here I'm your brother
come to me don't come too close okay can
I just go whoa wait whoa hey
oh whoops I approached you too waited a
little bit okay god this is gonna take a
while isn't it Oh
why didn't I just get this how many
people are yelling at me that I didn't
get that when it was right in front of
my face what you got it back I gotcha
Fatal Frame yuh-huh well Babar via the
FAQ oh the fatal frame range of friggin
face god damn it you stupid stupid
stupid little girl
give me your fatal frame your your fatal
fram your feet'll friend
give me your fatal Fram about their yard
I'm gonna get you yeah yeah I got to go
straight a Fram hey the Fram oh yeah my
friend has been fatal
okay all right well now hear it again up
there yeah
Fatal Frame been ramped up cause Fela
Fram you look so good except you're so
dead you like my commentary now huh you
like this my battle commentary is
unmatched unparalleled man [ __ ] you look
so good but so sad
I'm not y'all so bad oh no I made a
little girl cry oh I feel so bad about
my lie
crimson diary both inside and outside
her pitch-black nobody's in the house
and I feel presents Sookie
help me I'm so scared I can't get out of
the closet help me at Sookie well that's
not good what I didn't get a key or
something god damn it I supposed to get
the bail key where's the bail key oh
well all right okay ah there must have
been something else that I miss like you
think I'm just supposed to keep hunting
Belles and then probably just take care
of that little girl it just obliterator
from this plane of existence over and
over again probably anyway I'm just
about out of time for this episode so
I'm gonna find a safe point I'm gonna
close this up because I've had enough
I've had enough oh yeah there's a boy
ready good good good good good
goody goody gumdrops gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme okay there we go all right
all that wandering was very annoying for
me too but I didn't make a lot of
progress even though it may seem not now
seemed like it was on his head that I
made a lot of progress okay
I know thank you everybody so much for
watching expect another episode fairly
soon here and as always I will see you
in the next video too much spin in my
see what this girl's egos gonna do to me
there ya go face first into it
be stuck on that forever